c'est plus qu'un avantage c'est un
privilège indu eux et c'est assez
scandaleux que dans les règles de
l'union européenne on ne prennent pas en
compte le fait qu un président ou un
premier ministre les autres pays
puissent être en campagne pendant qu'il
va présider l'europe c'est à dire qu'il
va jouir de toute cette mise en scène de
l'europe de tous ces chevaux qui vont
être braqués sur lui pour pouvoir faire
sa campagne sachant qu'en plus on a des
chances fois qu'ils sont minimes mais
qui existe quand même qu'ils ne
finissent pas ce mandat alors il
président lyon on aurait pu en choisir
de repousser cette présidence il a
refusé donc il sait très bien ce qu'il
fait il sait très bien le timing qui est
cette présidence donc pour lui au
contraire je pense que c'est un atout
majeur dans sa campagne alors il n'est
encore pas déclaré candidat mais on voit
que depuis septembre de toute façon il
est en campagne c'était le cas encore
cette semaine à vierzon et à vichy pour
ce qui sera de bruxelles clairement pour
lui il va pouvoir faire des discours
parlé au monde entier à voir cette
stature internationale qui fait qu'un
président de la république a toujours un
temps d'avancé sur des candidats qui
n'ont pas ce rôle là est donc clairement
il a choisi pour lui pour cette campagne
d'avoir cette présidence
[Musique]